so when you ended up deciding to leave
the NFL what did you do at first did you
go right to the trading pits or kind of
what was that journey like and what was
kind of the impetus for going into that
environment sure it's a it is a very
good questions because AI didn't leave
of my own volition they fired me they
cut me and you know it was one of those
deals pop where literally they come to
your door knock on the door and I know
I'm gonna get cut tomorrow I know I'm
gonna get cut and they'd leave because
they couldn't face that and when it
happened to me I was pretty sure that I
was going to be cut but I was still in
enough of denial you know the river in
Egypt where I thought well you know a
couple of these other guys left maybe
they need an extra linebacker to hang
around before Singletary you know what
if he get hurts himself or whatever he
never did the guy was like unstoppable
and that's the guy that beat me out Mike
Singletary so he did a great job he was
very good guy too so it would be easy to
hate the guy that you know that takes
the job from you but this guy was just
such a good guy you couldn't hate him
and I've always been a guy also that's
pretty honest with myself as far as my
abilities so when I meet somebody who is
better than me
could be in trading you know I've met
guys that are better than me it could be
in skiing and it happened to be in
football you know and I was just like
yeah I get it he's better than me and
the coach was like yeah we're sorry you
know not everybody can make it you know
how it is John blah blah blah and I'm
like hey man I appreciate the
opportunity thank you yeah that's
awesome and I mean look to be completely
Frank Wright playing linebacker Chicago
Bears no matter how long it was is
is one amazing and then to to to hang
out and meet with guys like my
Singletary and kind of all of the
players that went through that
organization is obviously life
experience a lot of people will impact
right yeah I agree
and luckily I had one bad injury in high
school and nothing after that so you
know I've seen guys with their shoulders
cut their knees cut their hands my
brother Pete has broken every finger at
least once and his thumbs twice so yeah
there's a lot of injuries and things
that guys get that i luckily avoided
yeah that's awesome and and so help me
understand as you decide okay I'm gonna
go kind of build a career in finance and
trading did you already know people and
kind of have a back-up plan was it like
okay I got cut and now all of a sudden I
gotta go figure this out like what what
happened kind of post getting cut from
the NFL that eventually launched the the
career in finance again that's a great
question because since my dad was a
doctor and he was pretty famous I mean
in his field he was you know like at if
not the zenith you know right up there
on the top of the mountain
he developed a bunch of anti-rejection
drugs for people when they got
transplants and things like that so he
was very famous and he's the chief
surgery at the University of Minnesota
for like 38 years so the choices were I
could go up there but I could stay there
but I'd always be in his shadow I
thought and no shame in that
but I wanted to kind of forge my own
path and so my agent was putting some of
his representative players because he
had hockey players skiers baseball
players that kind of stuff I mean famous
people like Rod Carew and Allan page
they were his clients so he was putting
some of those guys on the trading floor
because they had what he thought was
Ness
Cerrie to be successful in trading they
were disciplined they were excitable
they were physical and he thought those
kinds of things would make you a good
trader now he knew you of course you
needed to learn that all the other stuff
too but if you didn't have those things
some people were putting like
professional blackjack players on the
floor because if you can count cards you
can be a pretty good trader and I agree
that's a good skill I knew a guy that
could count three decks of cards and you
know beat you on virtually every hand be
and he was banned he had to you know
when he'd go to Vegas or Reno he'd have
to go in a wig and things like that I
mean you know he was kicked out of more
casinos but he was not good in the pit
even though he was a good trader because
he wasn't aggressive enough and so like
I say my agent was looking for guys that
were aggressive that could learn the
other stuff some of these guys were like
professional chess players you know
grandmasters in chess and you might
imagine that you and I probably know
guys that are like that they tend not to
be terribly aggressive you know it's all
up here
and so they'd put on a position and
they'd walk away and you know hopefully
they put on enough edge that they could
make money from putting that position on
but they couldn't stand down there in
the pit and grind it out like the rest
of us could because they weren't
aggressive enough it's a physical you
know back then anyway it was very
physical you couldn't hit people but you
could throw elbows and things like that
people didn't want you standing in their
spot so being bigger I'm still about 6 2
and 215 back then I was 6 to maybe 250
um so I was a bigger guy you know
broader shoulders and things so you
could intimidate people and that was
very valuable in the pit and John
explained that a little bit more cuz
there's a lot of people listening who
have no idea how the pits worked
especially back then and when you're
talking about it being more physical and
kind of the jockeying for positions and
things like that like unpack that a
little bit and explain what was
happening sir well so you're in the
trading pit and a pit is an octagon just
like you know the UFC fights in except
they have steps that go up usually like
three or four feet in the air each step
is let say you know six or eight inches
so there might be four steps up four
steps down into the middle of the pit
and each ring if you will of that pit is
about eighteen inches wide so you could
stand on that but it's not exactly like
standing on a 2x4 there's enough room
that you can kind of walk around on it
but you could also fall off of it and
you know so sometimes when traders were
standing in their spot if all of a
sudden a trade was happening on the
other side of the pit everybody would
rush towards that side of the pit so
it's all salt oh and they're stumbling
down the steps and things as they go
over to that side of the pit so the pits
are set up so that from the top ring of
the pit you can see all the trading
desks around the floor if you're down in
the middle of the pit you can't even see
out of the pit you're just looking at
guys bellies and things like that so the
more active trader you are you're at the
top and the less active you are or the
newer you are you're down at the bottom
so the guys at the bottom tended to hold
positions for a long time the guys that
want to buy so buy sell all day long
they're at the top and the brokers want
to stand next to the guy that's actively
trading because by
rule they can't trade against their own
paper so if I have an order from a
customer I'm calling that paper I cannot
take the other side of this trade I have
to open outcry it into the pit and say
55 calls and the pitch screams back you
know one to a quarter and I can say I'll
pay 115 and then they might say at a
quarter at a quarter at a quarter and
then if I can't buy them at 115 and the
order is not held meaning I can pay any
price I want I might say a hundred and
hundred I bought 200 I'm out I'm 115 bid
for 200 more or whatever so that trade
would happen with those two guys they'd
all right each other's names down on the
pit on the card rather the sellers would
write down who they sold to the buyer
would write who he bought from and then
they turn in their cards so all of this
got processed at the end of the day when
I started then as trading became faster
and faster and faster it eventually
moved to handheld computers then it
moved to you know at almost light speed
to laptops and then you don't need
traders on the floor anymore now you can
make that market pop from New York or
from Philly or from Macau it doesn't
matter so you don't need to be in the
pits anymore
so the pits went from very profitable
places to be where you know if there's
3,000 traders down there you know they
might be taken a couple billion dollars
home every year and all of a sudden you
know most of that gets taken by
high-frequency guys and now the traders
on the floor these days you know if
you're still on the floor maybe you make
a hundred hundred and fifty thousand
bucks instead of a couple million or ten
million whatever you could make before
and you multiply that times you know two
or three thousand so you get where you
know the the big change came from now
there's almost no one on trading floors
all by machine